they pay us for it but right now we are
sort of speechless how do you feel right
now sum up your feelings for us I think
at some point I started shaking
and I'm still I'm still in a kind of a
tilt
in a must-win situation twice today then
Fabiano was also in a must win situation
and managed to come back then at the end
of it you just threw your hands up in
the air and you made a sign like this
what were your feelings no I was very
happy I just uh you know at that moment
when you achieve something as my
psychologist told you you have to kind
of celebrate at that moment who is your
psychologist
but no the thing is I'm I mean no
disrespect yes to Fabiana his close
friend of mine yes but at that moment
it's just you know I want to be happy
do you ever feel whenever you're on the
other side any bad feelings or what do
you nothing right now no I mean of
course he feels upset and I would be
upset if I lost to him but at the same
time you you cannot just blame your
opponent if they're celebrating a win I
think this is a natural feel and unless
they're doing something excessive
laughing or doing something right this
is you know there there are ways to
celebrate things I think there are ways
to celebrate wins and I don't think I
ever
you know past that threshold where where
celebration turns into disrespect and as
you guys were getting ready for the
Armageddon we saw you laughing with
Fabiano chatting a little bit about the
upcoming game what do you were you guys
telling yourselves I told you I know
that we're creating content I've been
laughing about it with him I was saying
nowadays uh you know
really playing chess uh is not as
lucrative as creating content
uh you know it's just an inside joke
you're playing uh linear tomorrow that's
how you started the tournament with a
match against linear how do you
anticipate that one to go well I
definitely need a need to rest a bit
today and uh you know it's actually
playing against Lanier and playing
against Fabiano is a great joy for me
because they're my friends they're from
Saint Louis
and uh you know I don't mind losing
against them
absolutely guys join the conversation
any questions for our Victor uh I'm kind
of in shock myself I need to recover too
I would just say uh Lavon you put on
both of you put on a fantastic display
and uh
I just enjoyed everything about today
and and just simply congratulations it
was a great match it really was but tell
me yes sir this h6h5 then g69 H5 is this
something you you enjoyed seeing
no I was ashamed
no I did actually I like your G6 and I
liked your knight H5 especially I
thought that was really really really
creative uh well done I mean what a
match Jovi what a match yeah what a
story and the only thing that I want to
know is how on Earth did you quickly
recover
ah when you play too long and you know
the thing is when you play idiotic moves
this is something to be expected
but then you suddenly Play Good Moves
you get happy because this is something
unexpected so you get good emotions
I want to ask you about one particular
moment in this match when you found that
triangulation King G2 King F2 King F3
you did it three times that must have
given you an extra boost of energy I
didn't think it was working I think it
was the only way out yeah yeah
the only way but I thought it's still a
draw no it wasn't no that was that was
the winning but that game was ridiculous
because I blundered on he could take on
G2 and Rook V7 doesn't work because of
Rook F7 there was a big shame in that
game for me and I was uh yeah I think I
kept on blundering a lot but it's only
natural when you play against somebody
as strong as for piano who always poses
problems Levon congratulations we'll let
you go get some rest and get ready for
tomorrow's match thank you very much
definitely our congratulations wow I
just I'm still Aston